[Música]
estamos em plena segunda guerra mundial
eo jogo não é chamado pra frente de
batalha na rússia no cáucaso
nessa batalha é frente unificada e entre
os deputados o projeto está na manhã em
um comboio obrigado a ficar mais grave
encontrado os refugiados placas mãe e
filha que um acabado pois é tudo às mãos
do exército russo e para a sua família
tinha sido enviada para os campos de
concentração será amanhã o jovem ajuda
destas séries e começarem a sua vida e
nesse processo
na véspera de natal ele se apaixonar por
mais nova
pouco tempo depois casam e no pós guerra
apesar das dificuldades que eu quero é
obviamente a vida social cria um pequeno
negócio não seria o jovem começa a
marcar num de paz ea sogra sociedade é e
arrumada ea ali como era conhecido e
começou a ver o seu negócio por cento é
evoluir
alexandre passavam férias no adriático e
usavam das águas transparentes à vista
paradisíaca nas viagens gratuitas horas
e não procurar um novo local para
acampar e encontraram o filho vem aqui
ao filho ligado ao filho e portugal
apaixona sido enviado
votaram todos os anos já com a sua filha
que cresceu entretanto e ela própria é
apaixonada por um português sempre casar
e ficar namorar cá em portugal ali ea
sua mulher
não criamos praças o filho de seus netos
e de serem eles próprios comprar em uma
casa no sítio onde acampavam no processo
de mudança
ela sempre as coisas que trazem trazem
um de fumeiro na sua mercearia na unha é
tão bonita que parece mentira mas é
verdade e como ela é verdadeira ela não
termina aqui
filipe neto e arde um dia voltar a casa
eu vou e outras coisas que começar a ver
ver o formato que lembra imediatamente
vem a sua memória o resultado se passava
com seu vôo e com esta ensinar como é
que era arte de fumar e começa a pensar
que nós em portugal não temos uma arte
de fumar pois temos disse maniche mas
apesar temos uma cultura tão grande do
país
nos falamos depois resolvi criar uma
marca harvey em homenagem a sua avó
esta marca cinza e tem no seu velho dois
mundos
[Música]
os portugueses também nós começamos uma
história brasileira como esta nós
sentimos a falta de papel da sua
honestidade guiné e tem graça não tem
caráter
ela também tem intensidade ela é
perfeita ela tem textura em pó e rolar a
festa distancia atrito e às vezes é
difícil
ela dizia que é verdade nunca poluída e
nunca é a verdade é que nada a ver -
valores atribuídos de imediato antônio e
melhor magalhães fazem parte da quarta
geração de uma família de guimarães e os
próprios encontraram naquilo que era
através da sua família algo que é
subestimado e trouxeram os nossos medos
canela portuguesa e não se sabe é
considerada uma das melhores jogadoras
do mundo e entende melhor maneira isso
criar uma marca só nela portuguesa
chamada pode estranhar esta marca
começou a criar camisetas trabalho e
quem sabe não só em homenagem à favela
mas também a todos aqueles com um com a
sua coragem e sua profissão ao mar há
homens da montanha exploradores
contribuíram para que o que é a cultura
da soja nela portuguesa
em seu primeiro ano conseguiu mais 30
pontos de venda com seus pecados da
nokia no ao pai para fundos da casa e
todas as férias eu aprendi na minha
posição da comunidade
nós vamos ter pelo menos duas regras há
muitas mais mas uma delas é que nós
vamos trabalhar com pessoas e não para
pessoas e em conjunto deus cure valor
onde muitas vezes não é pressionado
outra coisa companhia que nós só vemos
envolvermos com desafios com os quais
nós possamos solucionar os desafios que
nós podemos chegar a uma fórmula 1 temos
uma forma algum tempo leite que nós
temos a estar imediatamente que resulta
não há problemas com os quais nós
podemos envolver seriamente encontrar
uma solução com voz própria com
agilidade
essas geladeiras elas nunca são contadas
uma forma especial
elas não têm uma métrica não são
formalmente por trás disto porque não é
assim que o nosso cérebro organiza as
nossas memórias
outra coisa que estão jogando ontem é um
grande piloto final não é o clímax das
histórias acontecem como aconteceram
procuram vividas
eu sei que alguns vôos estão a pensar e
vou arriscar dizer a 0 e tal mas não tem
na minha família uma história tão
perfeita como base a lei
eu e minha família não está em um
tesouro escondido uma flanela praxe só
não eu não tenho na minha vida pessoal
na minha história pessoal
nada é composta criar ao já valor
leonard nimoy disse uma vez que eu tenho
não ser o mais alto que não ser mais
forte nem mais inteligentes mas é uma
coisa que eu podia fazer melhor qualquer
outra pessoa será o próprio
o irônico é que vocês conhecem eu
conheço do animal e como spock em star
trek
o mais irônico estudo é que spock
leonard nimoy sabia fundamento qual é o
valor da sua identidade
saí porque é primeira autobiografia
escreveu ken na capa a seguinte frase
i'm not spock maioria na alemanha em
animais sabia que nós devemos investir
em nossos valores em criar a nossa
identidade
muito mais do que tentar copiar a outra
pessoa qualquer
félix through e era um cliente meu cria
criar um entrave para sua empresa sempre
a 0 e foi especiais pós produção do
vídeo e era conhecido por troe félix
trombini e automaticamente já em talca e
depois outro e mais outro tanto recusou
e coação esta premissa achava que era um
nome monstruoso no disco e tentei fugir
de algum medo
em conversa com ela nós chegamos à
conclusão que nós vamos ajustar daquilo
não e criamos uma identidade para a sua
empresa que se tornou muito interessante
nós queremos é fantástico um ser
sobrenatural porque eles querem fazer
nós dois todos e temos essa consciência
são resultados de singularidade
todos nós somos diferentes e ns
singularidade que nós podemos criar
idéias e se vez podem criar valor
nós queremos deixar a nossa marca no
mundo nós podemos ter com os quants
todos os lados que eu aqui hoje relata
os problemas estou aqui hoje rotai
partem de pessoas que venceram várias
coisas e se vencer o silêncio ea inércia
serão às vezes o que está oculto para o
voar e mais que tudo vencer o fim das
histórias porque as histórias têm todas
um fim mas o bravo essa continua no dia
seguinte
[Aplausos]